Legislators.
Yes,
Percy.
We appreciate that.
We understand that.
We know they publish that after you die,
but we,
we got the memo
by poets.
He wasn't talking about versify or do
you?
He wasn't talking about folk who write
words on a page.
He was talking about all human beings
who mustard imagination and empathy to
conceive of an alternative reality given
the nightmares,
catastrophic driven realities.
Most of us have to come to terms with
which means to live a life of a certain
kind is to be a poet,
an artist of life and artists of living.
One Who through ones deeds and actions
and witness exemplifies and imagination
and an empathy that is subversive in
terms of relating to the past which just
has four to two and courageous in the
present to pass on to the next
generation.
Some wind at their back.
If you're wanting to know what hope he
is.
Just zoom in and August of 1955 within
materials.
Mother,
when she's asked to speak before,
not just public but the whole world
because the cameras were there from all
the various nations and there's her baby
in the coffin with the coffin open.
They tried to make sure they kept a
coffin closed.
She said,
no,
they're going to keep it open.
We just fetched his body from the
Tallahatchie River in Jim Crow,
gut bucket,
Mississippi Keel by cowardly hateful
American terrorists,
white supremacists.
We going to keep it open.
This is my only baby.
What you got to say Mamie till to the
world.
I'm not speaking on behalf of myself.
She says,
I'm not speaking on behalf of black
people are America.
I'm speaking on behalf of the bests of
the humans
bcs,
which is what I don't have a minute to
hate.
I will pursue justice for the rest of my
life.
That's been a hope.
It's an echo,
that magnificent moment and Ryan home
neighbors,
1932 classic more men in the moral
society where Ryan Hall says any
justice.
There's only justice soon degenerate
into something less than justice.
Justice must be rescued by something
grander and deeper than justice.
Mainly love,
love,
justice,
not identical,
but in the visible.
When Martin says,
justice is what love looks like in
public,
he's talking about it in the legacy of
Jerusalem,
not the legacy of Athens for Plato.
Justice as a norm
to giving and having ones do,
but an Amos justice is a force,
is a major force.
It's an answer to the question of Walter
Hawkins and his song,
what is this?
How do I count for this fire I have
inside of me that want to give me any
piece?
I've got to somehow get it out and if I
don't do something to rock,
so going to cry out,
that's as substantial.
I wouldn't even call it spiritual
because we know religious folk have no
monopoly on it.
Given the history of religious
institutions,
accommodating themselves to the most
vicious phones have beastiality and
atrocity be against our Jewish brothers
and sisters in the history of
Christianity.
It could be against Muslims,
it can be against everything because
women,
I'm gazing levels of black folk or
whatever.
Thank God for the history of the
heretics and the blast famous.
That's my crowd.
Look at the history of communism.
My God,
every self conscious Marxists finds him
or herself usually having to leave the
communist party in order to be true to
the best of Karl Marx.
Why?
Because of the ossification and a pet to
vacation of institutions in that way.
Hope is that substantial.
Keep coming back to that point.
And the issue of integrity that the boys
raised is quintessential.
And of course we live in an age of what?
Cupidity love of money.
I didn't say stupidity.
That's too easy.
Even though that's part of the problem,
but it's cupidity
cause it wouldn't be a Donald Trump if
it wasn't for Wall Street corporate.
He leads the Republican Party that was
so complicitness and willing to adjust
themselves to it or even a democratic
part of this too.
Milk,
toast and acts like they want to be part
of the resistance but usually have to be
brought in kicking and screaming because
the Deimos wake up and just hit the
streets.
The way the system is did the day after
the inauguration night,
it hit hit the airports the way our
precious brothers and sisters in
solidarity with and following,
so call undocumented brothers and
sisters.
It's all those little ones we've been in
the vanguard,
those are the poets,
the artists,
the van guard of the species.
Integrity over against cupidity and
venality and the saddest feature of our
present moment and that's why you all
were so visionary because you all came
up with this day and age of Obama.
I see for a lot of people,
they didn't need to talk about hope.
I know Obama because Obama has already
provided in the hope.
Of course.
I didn't get that memo.
That's another lecture.
We're not going to get into that
tonight.
No,
no.
Well,
I'm suspicious of anybody tagged the
wall of speak military industrial
complex assassinating American citizens
without accountability.
I'm critical of antibody antibody,
the top 1% getting 95% of the income
growth and 94% of the job that you brag
about a short term contemporary,
temporary,
precarious jobs that somehow you're
going to talk about the low unemployment
rate.
Why don't you just take a look at these
brushes folk in these communities
dealing with these two or three jobs,
trying to put it all together.
Start with the university with adjunct
professors.
Go Brag to me about how wonderful the
status quo is and therefore death.
Do you hope,
but that's another lecture.
My point is this.
Yeah.
My point is this,
that everybody's for sale.
Okay.
Everything is for sale.
Your glucose was right.
Pervasive,
ubiquitous commodification tied to
militarization in our relations with one
another and the relations with police
and local citizens,
relation of CIA,
State Department and Pentagon to Yemen
and Pakistan and Afghanistan and in
relation to undermine democratic regimes
in Honduras in relation to Libya in
relation to the West Bank under Israeli
occupation in relation to poor doers,
folk inside of Israel,
given the increasing wealth inequality
within Israel itself,
commodification,
militarization.
And then of course nigger residx.
What is Nigga realization?
The attempt to make sure the dose slash
don't call everyday.
People are so scared and intimidated and
afraid and feeling so hopeless and
helpless that they'll never straighten
their backs up.
Walking around feeling is there.
They can't make a difference.
The voices don't matter.
You can hear by the Martin Luther King,
same from the grave it time ordinary
people's straighten their backs up to
going somewhere cause fuck k ride your
back unless it bent.
And that's an echo of the and Walden
when he talks about the sleep walkers
and it has the sleep,
the focal walking on their backs and the
when they wake up and stay woke.
And that just they walked away.
Our presses,
young folk talk about it.
Black lives matter,
but stay four to five as you awoke.
Okay.
Then the folk who are walking on your
back find sales in situations that's
called revolution
revolution.
Mine Revolution and values revolution
and priority is a transformation of self
and community and society,
and there is no transformation
without positive transformation,
without this dialect to go into play of
love as a form of death from which hope
emerges in the form of action.
Hmm.
[inaudible].